hello everyone my name is leah schmidt
and i'm a postdoctoral fellow working
the laboratory of dr philip greenberg at
the fred hutchinson cancer research
center in seattle today i'm going to
tell you a bit about my work using
genetically engineered pre-clinical
models to study t-cell therapy against
solid tumors
immune checkpoint therapy is a cancer
treatment modality that has transformed
the field of oncology over the past
decade
these therapies function by blocking
checkpoint pathways that suppress t cell
function thereby unleashing powerful
anti-tumor immune responses
immune checkpoint therapy has become the
standard of care for many cancer types
importantly not all tumor types are
observed to respond to checkpoint
therapy equally
indeed one of the first recognized
predictors of responses to these
therapies was tumor mutational burden
tumor types associated with the
acquisition of high numbers of mutations
tend to respond better to checkpoint
inhibition
however there is significant
heterogeneity and tumor mutational
burden
even within each tumor type
for instance lung adenocarcinoma one of
the biggest cancer killers in the united
states and worldwide and a disease for
which checkpoint blockade is now
standard of care exhibits a wide
spectrum of mutational load across
patients
indeed not all lung cancer patients
respond equally to immune checkpoint
therapy only about half of lung cancer
patients enjoy long-term benefit from
checkpoint inhibition in combination
with chemotherapy shown here in green
digging deeper gene expression analysis
has revealed that patients whose tumors
exhibit a so-called t-cell inflamed
immune signature are more likely to
respond to checkpoint inhibition
thus the approximately half of lung
cancer patients who do not exhibit these
signs of pre-existing anti-tumor immune
responses may not be predicted to
respond to these therapies
one strategy for circumventing the need
for pre-existing anti-tumor immune
responses for therapeutic benefit is the
use of engineered t-cell therapy
pioneered in part by mypi phil greenberg
this strategy involves genetically
modifying a patient's t cells to
recognize and respond to tumors by
engineering them to express t cell
receptors that bind to tumor antigens in
the hopes of generating de novo
anti-tumor t cell responses
endogenous anti-tumor t-cell responses
are typically driven by recognition of
tumor neoantigens or mutated proteins
that are recognized as foreign by the
immune system
this explains why cancers associated
with higher mutational burdens are more
likely to exhibit signs of endogenous
t-cell responses
however engineered t-cell therapy allows
us to target a second class of tumor
antigens called tumor-associated
antigens
tumor-associated antigens are native
unmutated proteins which are apparently
overexpressed by cancers
because these are by definition self
proteins t cells that recognize
tumor-associated antigens are inherently
quite rare and unlikely to mount
productive anti-tumor responses
however engineered t-cell therapy allows
us to isolate these rare t-cell
receptors specific to tumor-associated
antigens and use them to program immune
patients own immune systems against
their tumors
unlike most neo-antigens
tumor-associated antigens are also often
shared across patients and even across
tumor types
this means that a single engineered t
cell receptor can be used to treat many
different patients
these therapies have been effective in
the context of blood-borne cancers
particularly in preventing disease
relapse in acute myeloid leukemia
patients
here patients treated with t cells
engineered to recognize cancer cells
were completely protected from disease
relapse and mortality compared to a 46
relapse rate in the comparative group
however solid tumors present many unique
challenges to anti-tumor t-cell
responses including physical molecular
cellular and energetic barriers to t
cell function
the use of engineered t-cell therapy
against solid tumors is still an active
area of investigation
in addition to human studies our lab
utilizes genetically engineered mouse
models to study the use of t-cell
therapy against solid tumors including
identifying the hurdles to effective
responses and strategies for overcoming
them
in these studies we isolate t cells from
donor mites and genetically engineer
them to express tumor-specific t-cell
receptors in culture
then we infuse the modified t cells into
animals bearing established tumors
to study their function and efficacy in
these systems
much of this work was pioneered by dr
ingen stromnez a previous postdoc in our
lab who now heads her own group at the
university of minnesota
ingan isolated and cloned a t-cell
receptor against a tumor-associated
antigen called mesothelion which is
commonly overexpressed across tumor
types
using a genetically engineered model of
pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma incan
showed that engineered t-cell therapy
could significantly prolong the survival
of tumor-bearing animals shown in red
this work has led to the initiation of a
clinical trial for testing the efficacy
of mesothelion-targeted
therapy against human pancreatic cancer
following on ingan's work i am studying
t-cell therapy in the context of lung
cancer utilizing a genetically
engineered mouse model of lung
adenocarcinoma called the kp model
in this system the mice are engineered
to carry
pre-recombinase-inducible mutations in
the proto-oncogene keras and the tumor
suppressor p53 the two most frequently
mutated genes in human adenocarcinoma
delivery of cree into the cells of the
lung through the use of lentiviruses
causes the activation of oncogenic k-ras
and the deletion of the tumor suppressor
p53 leading to the progressive
development of lung adenocarcinoma over
the course of several months that
histologically and transcriptionally
recapitulates human disease
we believe that these models are useful
for studying immune responses against
tumors because they recapitulate the
natural progression of tumor development
in situ alongside fully competent immune
systems
we think this is important because the
tumor microenvironment likely plays a
large role in immunotherapy outcomes
importantly the mesothelion
tumor-associated antigen is commonly
overexpressed in human lung
adenocarcinoma
and is associated with poor prognoses
interestingly mesothelion overexpression
seems to be associated with k-rat
mutations in human lung cancer
indeed we observe mesothelioma
overexpression and kp genetically
engineered mouse model lung tumors
similar to human disease
however we also observe expression of
mesophyll and protein by some healthy
tissues within the pleural cavity
including the heart and the lung airway
epithelium
thus this model allows us to evaluate
the risks associated with off tumor on
target toxicity
when we infuse t cells engineered to
recognize the mesothelion antigen into
kp tumor varying mice we observe
significant enrichment of these cells
shown by the black dots in the
tumor-bearing lung compared to
controlled targeted t cells shown by the
white dots
we are able to significantly extend the
survival of kp lung tumor-bearing
animals by repeated infusion of
mesothelioma-specific t-cells as shown
by the red line in the kaplan myograph
on the left which corresponds to slower
weight loss by these animals compared to
controls shown on the right
unfortunately the survival benefit is
relatively modest and animals do
eventually succumb to disease
importantly though we know that some
healthy tissues do express low levels of
the mesothelion antigen such as the
heart and lung airway epithelium as i
showed you earlier we do not observe t
cells accumulating at those sites or any
other apparent signs of toxicity
here i'm showing you histological
sections from mice treated with
mesothelion-specific t-cells on the left
or control targeted t cells on the right
the bottom two rows show standing for
the t cell markers cd3 you can see that
mesodeal and targeted t cells primarily
accumulate in and around tumors and the
blood vessels in close proximity to
tumors
so in summary of the first part of our
talk
i've shown you that checkpoint
inhibition is effective against many
cancer types but not all patients
benefit
tumor mutational burden and t cell
inflamed phenotypes correlate with
positive outcomes indicating that
patients without pre-existing anti-tumor
t-cell responses may not be predicted to
benefit
engineered t-cell therapy against these
tumors associated antigens is a strategy
for initiating de novo anti-tumor t-cell
responses and they've been shown to be
effective against blood-borne cancers
solid tumors present additional
obstacles to anti-tumor t-cell responses
and adoptive cellular therapy in solid
tumor settings is still an active area
of research
i've shown you that genetically
engineered mouse models like the kp lung
model recapitulate many salient features
of solid tumor biology and we've shown
that mesophyll and targeted t-cell
therapy extends survival in kp
tumor-bearing mice although the benefit
is limited and the animals do eventually
succumb to disease
importantly we don't observe any signs
of toxicity against healthy tissues
so the next question that we came upon
was you know really how relevant are
these sophisticated genetically
engineered mouse models to clinical
disease
turning back to the clinical data we
know that tumor mutational burden and
t-cell phenotypes predict responses to
checkpoint blockade therapy so we ask
the question which patient subsets are
best recapitulated by our kp genetically
engineered mouse model
importantly one of the principal
limitations of using engineered mouse
models to study immunotherapy is that
they generally do not acquire many
additional genetic lesions other than
the engineered mutations in contrast to
many human cancer types
as a result these tumors tend not to
recruit an endogenous anti-tumor t cell
response since there's very little
opportunity for the acquisition of
strong tumor neoantigens
in line with these observations the
pitet group at the massachusetts general
hospital showed that kc tumors do not
respond to immune checkpoint therapy
either in terms of survival on the left
or tumor burden on the right
however dr michael dupage a graduate
school colleague of mine who now has his
own lab at uc berkeley pioneered the use
of model neoantogens in the kp lung
cancer model
he called this the leukos model
expressing a chimeric protein consisting
of luciferase fused to of albumin and
cerebral antigens two commonly used t
cell antigen systems
michael engineered the lung tumors to
express these antigens by cloning them
into the lentiviruses used to initiate
tumors in this model
in this setting t cells do accumulate
within tumors as shown in the bottom
panels
however tumor-specific t-cells
progressively acquire features of
dysfunction in this model including
declining numbers and cytokine
production capacity as well as
expression of the suppressive checkpoint
molecule pd1
p-tech group showed that these
neoantigen-expressing tumors are capable
of responding to immune checkpoint
therapy when administered in combination
with so-called immunogenic chemotherapy
or auxaliplatin
based on these data we may predict that
the conventional kp model may more
closely mimic human lung cancers that
are unlikely to benefit from checkpoint
inhibition or non-t-cell inflamed
disease
on the other hand we might expect that
lung tumors engineered to express tumor
new antigens might better recapitulate t
cell inflamed disease
we sought to test this experimentally
additionally we set out to determine the
effects of administering engineered t
cell therapy on tumor immune phenotypes
in each of these two settings
in order to test this we turned to
clinical data sets generated by our
colleagues in the laboratory of dr
mcgarry houghton at fred hutch
the houghton lab performed unsupervised
hierarchical clustering of human
non-small cell lung cancers based on
immune cell profiling by split cytometry
they found that these cancers clustered
into four groups
first inert with very few immune
infiltrates of any kind second
myeloid dominated by myeloid subsets
primarily driven by neutrophils
third active characterized by high
levels of t-cell infiltration similar to
t-cell inflamed cancers and fourth
indeterminate with no clear pattern of
immune infiltration identified but
characterized by high levels of th17
type cytokines
the hoten group also identified an
immune signature that was elevated in
the active human lung cancer subset
including genes involved in cytotoxic t
cell responses and interference gamma
signaling
to perform a similar analysis on our
genetically engineered mouse model
tumors we generated kp tumors with or
without the expression of neoantigens
using the leukos system and with or
without administered engineered t cell
therapy and subjected these tumors to
transcription analysis using
nanostring's encounter pan cancer io 360
panel
we compiled a list of mouse genes
corresponding to the hoten active immune
signature that were present in our
analysis panel and assess the expression
of these genes by each kp tumor type
we observed that untreated tumors shown
in yellow express relatively low levels
of active immune signature genes
interestingly both the introduction of
tumor neoantigens shown in gray and the
administration of engineered t-cell
therapy shown in purple boosted active
signature gene expression
and neoantigen expressing tumors that
also receive t-cell therapy shown in red
were the most enriched for the signature
these data suggest that neo
expression and engineered t-cell therapy
are both able to skew kp tumors toward
an active immune phenotype
next we utilize the end solver software
to perform cell type profiling based on
the transcripts present in each sample
interestingly the untreated tumors shown
in yellow and gray clustered together
regardless of neoantigen expression
whereas the treated tumors shown in
purple and red clustered separately
focusing on predicted t cell infiltrates
similar to the active immune signatures
the untreated kp tumors in yellow showed
the lowest t-cell score while the
neo-antigen-expressing tumors that
received t-cell therapy in red scored
the highest and the tumors that
expressed either
either expressed neoantigens in gray or
received t-cell therapy in purple fell
in the middle
next we wanted to establish which human
non-small cell lung cancer subset is
best recapitulated by kp tumors at
baseline
focusing on these tumors in yellow we
observe that they are not devoid of
immune cells as measured by cd45 score
in the top left spot
however they were not particularly
enriched for either t cells or myeloid
subsets shown in the other three plots
digging deeper we analyzed the
expression of genes that the houghton
study found to be associated with either
the indeterminate group or the myeloid
group
compared to treated tumors the untreated
kp tumors were enriched for expression
of th17 cytokines associated with the
indeterminate class of human lung
cancers
but not with myeloid class associated
genes
thus we concluded that the kp lung tumor
model most closely recapitulates the
indeterminate class of human non-small
cell lung cancer
so in summary the second part of my talk
i've shown you that kb lung tumors
require few mutations harbor few t-cell
infiltrates and a recalcitrant
checkpoint inhibition similar to human
non-small cell lung cancers that do not
benefit from immune checkpoint therapy
introduction of model neoantogens as
shown by michael dupage's work increases
t-cell infiltrates and renders tumors
sensitive to immune checkpoint therapy
as shown by the ptet lab in combination
with immunogenic chemotherapy
cell type profiling and active immune
signatures indicate that kp lung tumors
most closely resemble the indeterminate
class of human non-small cell lung
cancers
and neoantigen expression and or the
administration of engineered t-cell
therapy remodels the tumor
microenvironment to a more active
phenotype
following on this work we're performing
single cell expression analyses to
determine heterogeneity within the lung
tumor microenvironment and therapeutic
t-cell substrates and changes in
phenotypes within these cells with
therapy
these observations allowed us to ask if
t cell therapy is capable of remodeling
the tumor micro environment to a more
active phenotype then why does this
therapy ultimately fail in this setting
one important reason why we believe
t-cell therapy does not provide
long-term benefits in this system is
that the therapy of t-cells appear to
lose function very rapidly in the lung
tumor micro-environment
in this assay we harvested therapeutic
t-cells from either the lung or from the
spleen as a control tissue seven days
after infusion into the animals
we stimulated them with mesothelioma
peptide in culture and measured their
capacity to produce cytokines
even at this very early time point after
infusion t cells harvested from the
lungs had significantly less cytokine
production capacity compared to those
coming from the spleen
interestingly though t-cell therapy
significantly prolongs survival in both
the lung and pancreatic cancer models
shown at the top
t-cells seem to lose function much more
rapidly in the lung tumor
microenvironment compared to the
pancreas tumor microenvironment as
measured by the same exterior
stimulation i previously described shown
in the bottom two graphs
this might help explain why the survival
extension in the lung cancer model which
is only about two and a half weeks is
more modest than that seen in the
pancreatic cancer model which is about
six weeks and suggests the existence of
tumor or tissue type specific factors in
the suppression of therapeutic t cells
interestingly we observed that this loss
of function is linked to antigen
exposure that is when we infuse t cells
specific to a control antigen that is
not expressed in the tumor
microenvironment here labeled as ot1 in
blue into tumor varying animals and then
stimulate them ex vivo with their
cognate antigen they do not lose
function to the same extent as the
mesothelion specific t cells shown in
red
that is unless we program the tumors to
express the control antigen in which
case these t cells do lose function to a
similar extent as the mesothelion
mesothelion-targeted t-cells
delving deeper into potential mechanisms
of t-cell suppression we perform bulk
transcriptional analysis on therapeutic
t-cells isolated either from the lung
tumor microenvironment or the spleen of
the controlled tissue in mysparine kp
tumors with or without model neoantigens
utilizing nanostrings encountered t cell
exhaustion panel
using the end solver software principal
component analysis revealed that the
therapeutic t cells clustered primarily
according to the tissue from which they
were harvested regardless of whether
the tumors expressed neo-antigens or not
pathway analysis revealed stark gene
expression changes occurring in the lung
tumor microenvironment
we saw the enrichment of genes
associated with t cell or t cell
receptor activation and altered
metabolism in the lung tumor
microenvironment compared to the spleen
consistent with ongoing antigen-induced
t-cell responses in this tissue
cytokine signaling signatures were also
upregulating upregulated highlighting
the complex immunology encountered by
therapeutic t cells in this setting
gene sets associated with t cell
function dysfunction such as energy
apoptosis senescence and quiescence and
t cell exhaustion were enriched in the
lung tumor microenvironment and cell
cycle pathway genes were decreased
possible contributors to t cell
dysfunction identified by pathway
analysis where hypoxic stress inhibitory
cytokines such as il-10 and tgf-data
signaling
checkpoint pathways and terminal
differentiation or exhaustion as
measured by epigenetic modification
to date we've only just begun to scratch
the surface in determining the relative
contributions of each of these pathways
and contributing to t-cell dysfunction
however one logical strategy for
boosting anti-tumor t-cell function
in tumors is the use of immune
checkpoint therapy
indeed we do observe increased
expression of checkpoint receptors on
therapeutic t cells from the long tumor
micro environment compared to endogenous
t cells shown in gray and we observe
that kp tumor cells do express
checkpoint ligands as shown on the
bottom
indicating that these pathways might be
active in the kp model in the context of
t-cell therapy
however when we administered immune
checkpoint therapy blocking all three of
these checkpoint pathways alongside
t-cell therapy
we did not observe any increase in
therapeutic t-cell function with
checkpoint therapy in blue compared to
t-cell therapy alone in red
in both cases t-cells harvested from the
lung exhibited similarly diminished
levels of function compared to those
coming from the spleen
these results indicate that checkpoint
blockade alone is not sufficient to
boost therapeutic t-cell function in
this setting and the other factors might
be acting to suppress t cell function
importantly others have shown that
inclusion of immunogenic chemotherapy
boosts the impact of checkpoint blockade
in similar animal models as i showed you
earlier highlighting the potential
importance of engaging innate immune
subsets
we have planned to test immune
checkpoint therapy in combination with
immunogenic genetic chemotherapy namely
auxiliary platinum in this setting
we're currently pursuing experiments in
which we can disrupt known suppressive
cell types that we have observed are
present in the kp lung tumor
microenvironment
for example by multiplex immunohistic
chemistry we observe the presence of
neutrophils here labeled in circles as
cd11b y6g double positive cells in and
around kp lung tumors after t cell
therapy
we also observe the presence of
regulatory t cells here labeled in
circles as cd4 fox p3 double positive
cells in close proximity with cytotoxic
t cells labeled with arrows
in the lung tumor micro environment
both of these cell types
t-regs and neutrophils have been shown
to inhibit anti-tumor t cell responses
in lung cancer and we have studies
underway in which we're depleting each
of these subsets to determine their
respective impacts on therapeutic t-cell
function
in the meantime we have begun to pursue
strategies for modifying therapeutic
t-cells to be resistant to suppressive
factors in the long-term
microenvironment
for example dr shannon oda a previous
postdoc in our lab who now has her own
group at seattle children's developed
immunomodulatory fusion proteins or ifps
these are chimeric molecules consisting
of the extracellular portion of
inhibitory receptors to use to the
intracellular portion of co-stimulatory
receptors such that binding to what
would normally be an inhibitory ligand
triggers a stimulatory
signal in the engineered t cell
for example
kp tumors express high levels of the
cd47 don't eat meat and innate immune
checkpoint ligand as shown in the bottom
right
shannon designed an isp that combined
the extracellular portion of the cd47
receptor surf alpha with the
intracellular signaling portion of the
cd28 t-cell co-stimulatory receptor
we found that inclusion of this isp in
our genetically modified t cells boosted
their function in the lung tumor micro
environment indicating that increased
co-stimulatory signaling can partially
overcome t-cell suppression in this
context
a second engineering strategy for
boosting t-cell function is the
inclusion of tumor-targeted helper
cd4-positive t-cells in our infusion
product
here we engineer cd4-positive t-cells to
recognize the same mhc class 1
restricted mesothelion antigen as our
conventional engineered cytotoxic cd8
positive t cells and we infused them
together into kp lung tumor varying
animals
we observed that inclusion of tumor
specific helper t cells boosted the
function of cytotoxic t-cells in the
lung tumor microenvironment indicating
that cd4 help can partially overcome t
cell suppression in this setting
so in summary of the last part of my
talk i've shown you that mesothelioma
targeted t-cell therapy does extend
survival in kp
lung cancer bearing animals but the
therapy of t-cells lose function rapidly
in the tumor micro-environment linked to
antigen exposure and leading to animals
to succumb to disease
immune checkpoint therapy alone fails to
boost therapeutic t-cell function in
this setting but we know that there are
suppressive cell types present within
the lung tumor microenvironment and we
have plans to test adjuvant therapies
targeting these populations
i've shown you some early experiments
testing strategies for boosting t-cell
function through engineering approaches
that have shown encouraging results and
i didn't have time to talk about this
today but our lab is also developing
cas9 based engineering approaches that
will allow us to more rapidly test the
effects of modulating candidate pathways
that are important for shaping t cell
phenotypes in the long-term micro
environment based on our immune
profiling data
so in conclusion of the talk i hope that
i've convinced you that t-cell therapy
does hold promise for patients who are
not likely to benefit from currently
available immunotherapies
genetically engineered balance models
are useful systems for evaluating the
efficacy of immunotherapies and for
elucidating the mechanisms of resistance
to therapies in tumor and tissue
specific contexts
however it's really important to
acknowledge the strengths and
limitations of genetically engineered
mouse models and to recognize the
relevance of these models to various
human disease settings
so with that i'd like to thank everyone
who was really instrumental to this
project including phil greenberg and all
the members of the greenberg lab both
past and present who were directly
involved in this project or who helped
me along the way
i'd also like to thank the university of
washington and fred hutch immunology
programs for all the useful help and
feedback
as well as my graduate lab the
laboratory of dr tyler jacks for many of
the reagents that you saw in today's
talk
i'd also like to thank the core
facilities of both the university of
washington and fred hutch as well as my
funding sources which are listed at the
bottom of the slide
with that i'd be happy to take any
questions if you just type them into the
the question
box and i i'd be happy to discuss this
work further with you so thank you very
much for your attention and have a great
day